do you enjoy about being a gamer ferns
in your character I think there's a lot
of different sides to Sam and I think in
just in this first episode in episode 4
of season 1 we see quite a broad
spectrum of those from an absolute
coward with no worth tall to somebody
who can make friends and make people
laugh and make people smile and coax
information our people and I think that
John starts to trust Sam very quickly
and it's nice to play the aspects of the
character that bring that out in people
it's a really kind of rounded did you
say characters it's complicated as well
so is that something you enjoy as an
actor that kind of meaty wrong oh
definitely definitely I think that
without any great drama you can stand on
the stage or in front of the camera and
have so much foundation to build your
performance on and Sam's because Sam's
backstory and his given circumstances
are explained so in detail and so kind
of vividly in that monologue on top of
the wall that gives you all the
information you need to know about how
this guy interacts with the world how we
interact with other people
what spurring him on what's driving him
forward what's keeping him back and I
think the writing in terms of getting
the characters inner feelings across
he's absolutely spawn
you mentioned the monologue there on top
of the wall I mean how kind of do you
psych yourself up flags it's something
it's really important isn't it for your
character well the good thing about that
scene was that was my audition scene and
the good thing about that is I knew the
lines won in advance and if you don't
have to think about remembering lines
you can concentrate more on bring in
more aspects of the scene out sometimes
if you're not quite because you always
know your lines but if you're not quite
sure on certain phrases and stuff it can
distract you from what you have to put
across but I felt very comfortable with
the Lions felt very comfortable with
KITT in that scene and really enjoyed it
that was the kind of mode that is not
only the pivotal scene for Sam in season
one I think the pivotal scene for Sam in
the whole series because up until then
he's been a complete mystery and people
don't really people don't really like
him up to that point because they've got
no idea why he's there why he's putting
himself through this what he's kind of
motivations are and he's quite a thief
frustrate people and it's only in that
scene that everything starts to click
into place so what can we expect from
Game of Thrones going forward hopefully
more of the same I think that season two
built very well on season one I think
that the balance of it was was really
really good all the characters gained
lots more kind of in terms of dimension
and depth and hopefully we can we trust
David and Dan and all the other writers
to go forward and build on that and
build on that and build on that and
doing the longer it goes on we're going
to end up with something very very
special indeed fingers crossed what do
you think has been the appeals people
cuz it has really taken off hasn't it
yeah I just think it's because fantasy
is one thing
but this is actual human beings being
placed in a fantasy setting it's not
aliens and it's not people that haven't
got human feeling and human emotion that
you can't connect to these people with
families and with ambition and with
human flaws and I think people not going
right the way about to kind of Greek
Theater and Shakespeare especially
people love to see that they love to be
you love to see humanity examined and I
think that's what Game of Thrones does
very quickly about a film that big film
that's coming out this year that you've
been involved with Anna Karenina what
can we expect from that and how was it
working with Joe Wright and Keira
Knightley's in it obviously as well that
was great
first time I've ever been on a on a
movie set didn't know what to expect
working with somebody like Joe who is a
master with using the camera use the I
mean look at that the the the bromine
camera shot in in atonement for a star
you just got look at that I was at the
pinnacle of somebody's work and I think
from the trailer it's going to be a very
beautiful film these great great script
Tom Stoppard script and very very
privileged to be involved in that as
well
loved it for seeing that look so weird
seeing the next game of Thrones as well
thanks for talking to us thank you very
much
you